well you've heard words there from
turkey's president richard tybe urged
one preceded by the un secretary general
antonio guterres let's just stay on
these pictures now see if they're uh
this agreement is due to be signed uh
now they uh
are there it was supposed to have
happened what about 45
48 minutes ago these things are often
delayed aren't they but let me bring you
some words what uh the un secretary
general had to say uh beacon of hope
and uh relief he talked about
on the possibility too on the black sea
the black sea beacon of hope he said was
shining bright he praised the
determination persistence of turkey to
broker and indeed secure this deal which
is about to be signed now
um there's no solution he said to the
world's food shortage without full
access to ukrainian grain and russian
food and fertilizer let's uh have a look
now at what's going on there
and the books they're
going to be assigning
and you can see
uh there is the un secretary general
russia's defense minister sergey shoigu
is their
ukrainian infrastructure minister to as
well as turkey's president and the man
you're looking at
in the his orange tie there um that is
the un secretary general
uh the un and turkey brokering this
historic uh agreement to allow
or certainly designed to allow 22
millions of grain and other agricultural
products through
black sea ports stuck for so many months
because of
the war
so let's just
sit on these pictures just for a moment
there as we do
so some significant words from the un
secretary general and turkey's president
speaking there dignitaries from russia
and ukraine let's bring in alex rossi so
we've been waiting for it haven't we
this agreement to be signed for around
uh 50 minutes alex uh it's uh that is
now
uh happening as we've heard some words
from the un secretary general and some
praise
for turkey
yeah i mean it is um whichever way you
look at it it is an extraordinary piece
of diplomacy remember that this
agreement that's been broken is
happening at a time when ukraine and
russia are locked in a
profoundly bitter fratricidal war that
is still raging across the country so
to see um two ministers from the
respective countries sitting down albeit
separated by a fairly long table
is really something of an achievement
now it's taken to get this far nearly
three months of negotiations as you can
imagine there isn't much trust there's a
great deal of suspicion on both sides of
each other's
motives but at the end the agreement has
been signed now the goal in all of this
is of course it's not about ending the
war that is a i think a long way off but
it is about reintegrating
the ukrainian food economy back into
global markets now something like 22
million tons of grain is currently
trapped in silos
in ukrainian ports primarily the
ukrainian port city of odessa
and it can't can't get out because of a
naval blockade that russia has put in
place since it launched its invasion on
the 24th of february now this agreement
is fairly is very focused but what it
should mean in time and according to
senior un officials it could be as soon
as
10 days perhaps two weeks when we see
the first ships leaving with grain but
it should me should mean eventually and
to get fully working it perhaps might
take a month because it is a big
logistical challenge but you could see
something like five million metric tons
of grain leaving ukrainian ports heading
through the black sea and uh into
turkish waters through the bosphorus
where it will be distributed around the
world particularly to countries in the
global south which are really facing
inflationary pressure as a result of the
cost of living crisis and the specter of
hunger and famine is becoming more and
more real every day now according to the
world food programme something like 47
million people are facing acute hunger
as a direct
consequence of this conflict and 71
million people according to the wfp are
being plunged into poverty as a direct
consequence of this
conflict so the urgency with which this
agreement now needs to be implemented is
extremely great now it is a it is a day
of hope it is a day of optimism you
heard the secretary general antonio
gutierrez
speaking there talking about a beacon of
hope on the black sea
um
but there are caveats in all of this as
i was saying earlier trust is a in very
short supply and it could be that even
though there isn't now on this agreement
that it could break down very easily
it's called the black sea initiative but
perhaps the best way of looking at it is
really as a ceasefire at sea
now the way the deal will work is it's
going to be
closely monitored by all
all sides in this the ukrainians the
russians the turks and also officials
from the united nations there'll be a a
joint coordination center set up in
istanbul which will monitor uh the ships
leaving ukrainian ports but crucially
and this was a sticking point uh in the
negotiations particularly for moscow
there will be physical inspections of
ships heading back um to ukrainian ports
to make sure that there won't be any uh
weapons on board those those ships that
ukraine could use to prosecute um the
war so that that's kind of where we are
at it's but of course as i was saying it
could break down but i think it's fair
to say
that this is you know this is a a big
moment
and it is a moment of hope
yeah we'll certainly see what happens
won't we alex thank you very much indeed
for being with us for the last hours
we've watched a moment of history
haven't we in istanbul there this
historic agreement to certainly try to
get
millions of tons of grain moving from
ukraine